okay uh we are on the final page
well done for staying with me uh this
long if you've been working all the way
through it
this question here um wasn't meant to be
too arduous if you read it carefully but
a lot of people got quite confused
so let's have a look at the language
that's being used and make sure
we know what's going on the arithmetic
mean of x and y
is the number a such that x a
y is an arithmetic sequence okay think
about this for a second
if i were to present to you um you know
two numbers like uh two and
say eight right x and y and they're on
both ends right
and the arithmetic mean of two and eight
is the number such that if you stick it
in here
you put it in place of a then you should
get an arithmetic
sequence so what number should i put in
there that would give me a common
difference all the way along that's what
defines an arithmetic sequence after all
hopefully your arithmetic is not failing
you and you realize oh it's going to be
a 5
right that gives me a common difference
of 3. so 5 is the arithmetic mean
of 2 and 8. and we would normally call
out the average
right so this is just a fancy name for
that because as we're introducing in
this question
the arithmetic mean is not the only kind
of mean there is also this
other term here the geometric mean
you can have a different mean for x and
y the same two numbers like 2 and 8
such that x and then your geometric mean
b and then y is a geometric sequence so
if i go back to 2 and 8
what's the number that i put in between
them such that
i don't get an arithmetic sequence with
a common difference
but i get a geometric sequence with a
common
ratio and maybe you've realized why i
chose 2 and 8
the number that you're going to stick in
here is 4 because that means that i've
got a common ratio
of 2. i'm doubling every time the next
number would be 16 32
and so on so in this case the arithmetic
mean or the am
for short is 5 and the geometric mean
the gm for short is 4. now what we're
then asked to prove in part 1
is prove that a is greater than or equal
to b
in other words that the am the
arithmetic mean is bigger
than the gm the geometric mean for all
positive real values
x and y in other words i didn't have to
just choose 2 and 8 i could have chosen
any two numbers
and the arithmetic mean will always be
bigger than the geometric mean how
do i prove that well um you've really
got to set this up
to sort of make it easy for yourself
right you can see i just gave a
numerical example so that i was i knew
what i was going on with here
but in order to prove this particular
result i need to phrase the arithmetic
mean and the geometric mean
in such a way to make this easy for me
to prove so here's the way that i've
done it
for xay to be an arithmetic sequence we
know we've got a common difference right
so
this is the definition of that common
difference so you get the arithmetic
mean being
x plus y on two which of course you
would think is the midpoint formula or
this is the way that i work out the
average of two numbers because that's
what we think of as the arithmetic mean
here's the geometric sequence
um you've got this common ratio
happening between the the pairs of terms
the consecutive pairs of terms i should
say
and so you've got b squared equals x y
um and i don't want b
squared i want b right so i've got plus
or minus the square root of
x y i do note that uh if you have a look
back
at the original question i've specified
that x and y have to be positive real
values
so in order to get a nice geometric
sequence here i want to say that i want
to specify for b
being positive if b were negative well
you know a is positive b is negative
of course a is bigger but the whole
point here is that
no matter which geometric mean that i
choose because
i could have i guess put in negative 4
here and it would have still worked
you're scared of a ratio of negative 2
but that's a trivial result right so i'm
thinking about the positive value that's
in between them
so therefore coming back to my solution
i'm specifying the positive value for b
the one that's bigger than x
it has to bigger than x because between
x and y i'm going to get b being the
square root
of x y so what i'm required to prove is
that this result here
the am is going to be bigger than this
result here
the gm so i guess i'm required to prove
that x plus y on 2 is greater than or
equal to the square root
of x y now i'm pausing right here
for two reasons number one it's always
helpful to state very clearly what it is
you're trying to prove
before you start to prove it and whilst
most questions um as you can see in this
paper and in the hse and any other exam
you're going to have
when you're proving something they tell
you exactly what they want you to prove
like just look at the previous example
like here is the actual equation i want
you to prove this
this question made it a little bit more
challenging by requiring you to
articulate yourself what you had to
prove and then work out the path there
on your own which
is an additional level of complexity so
there's the first thing um
sophistication i should say um that's
the first thing i want to state
the second thing is one of the things
we're consistently doing is recognizing
oh i want to prove something
and the first thing that you write is
that thing you're trying to prove and
then you go ahead and you do some
valid algebraic manipulation but you
don't get anything meaningful
because you started off assuming the
thing you were trying to prove
and that is always problematic um you
can apply
legitimate logical mathematical
operations
to something false and then arrive at
something true that doesn't mean the
premise was true
but you can do things very simple like
say for instance if i start off assuming
the 1 equals 2
which is not true if i multiply both
sides of this equation by the same
number
which is a valid mathematical operation
i end at a statement that is true
but it does not follow that the
statement that i began with was true
even if what i ended with
was true this is a fallacy so you cannot
begin
by assuming what you are trying to prove
it's a constant and easy mistake to make
so even if you say yeah this is where
i'm headed please do not start your
working from there
your working needs to end there not
start there
so as i mentioned before um it's often
you know the
this proof becomes easy if you know how
to set it up so what i've done is i've
said
x and y um they're going to be positive
real numbers that was given to me in the
question um and that means the square
root of x
and the square root of y will also be
real numbers um i wouldn't be able to
say that all the time if
x or y were negative for instance um
then the square root of x or the square
root of y might be
imaginary but i've already been
restricted within positive real numbers
so i can say the square roots are also
real numbers
if you've got two numbers that are both
real and you take the difference between
them
there's no way for a an imaginary
component to sneak in
so therefore the difference between two
real numbers is also
a real number so there we go the square
root of x minus the square root of y
is real um and that leads me to finally
now i've got an inequality i can
manipulate
if you square a real number then the
smallest it can be a zero because
you know the real number that would give
you that is zero itself if you wanted
something negative
you would need to have an imaginary
number up here and square that
but i don't i just went to great pains
to prove that the square root of x
minus the square root of y is real so
therefore when you square
a real number it has to be greater than
or equal to zero so many students just
said this without providing
evidence for why squaring it should give
you greater than or equal to zero
and then all i have to do here is some
fairly straightforward algebra i expand
out
i just get this over here on the right
hand side and i divide by two
to get the am on one side and the gm on
the other
so that's what i would advise a lot of
students
sort of caught themselves in twists
because instead of
dealing with the square root of x and
the square of y they just dealt with
something like say x minus y
or squared now that's not wrong x minus
y
or squared you might still say well x is
real y is real x minus y is real so
therefore when you square it you get
something greater than or equal to zero
so you ended up with something like this
now you can get to
the result that you need from here but
there's two reasons why
it's more complicated number one you've
got to deal with these squares in here
that's tricky and then number two you
actually end up having to take square
roots of both sides in order to turn
this
x y into a square root of x y and you
have to be quite cautious when you're
taking square roots
on two sides of an equation or an
inequality um you've got to be careful
with positiveness uh with parity
positive
that's that's oddness and evenness
you've got to be careful with sine which
is whether it's positive or negative
and a lot of people just took the square
root of both sides of an inequality
without making any statements as to why
you could take square roots
and you preserve the direction of the
inequality so great care needs to be
taken
which is what i was doing up here i
started with the square root of x and y
but if you do this path you just have to
take care of the positive and negatives
later
okay so that was part one uh what do we
then do with this amgm
inequality well it says hence which
means you had to use that result
by considering x equals this and y
equals this
find the minimum possible value of this
gross messy looking expression how do we
go about doing this well
please note that the question does say
hence so you're going to have to use the
mgm inequality somehow
and i know that's a bit counterintuitive
because most people who see this phrase
minimum or indeed minimum possible value
their brain their advance in extension
one brain says aha calculus
better differentiate and find a
stationary point somewhere okay now
there's two reasons
why you know that should not be the path
that you take reason number one
they told you use the a and gm
inequality which we just used earlier
how do you use an inequality to find a
minimum possible value well i'll get to
that in a second
and the second thing is how you know not
to differentiate and this um this
expression that you're dealing with here
let's highlight it rather than drawing a
messy oval around it
this expression you need to
differentiate it depends on two
variables
p and q it's a multi-variable expression
if you were then to differentiate what
would you differentiate with respect
to would it be p or would it be q
if you did it with respect to p you'd
have to treat q as constant or vice
versa
we haven't handled expressions like that
in
the course you don't unless you get to
university and do something called a
partial differential equation
which means you can take a
multi-variable equation or expression
like this which has p's and q's or
thetas and r's and you can differentiate
with respect to just one of the
variables
but no dice here you've got a p and a q
you've got to deal with both of them so
differentiation
calculus are not the answer what do we
do instead well the question again gives
you massive clues you've got
this x and y up here from the original
question
and then the question suggests hey let x
equal this let y equal that
and then see what happens so i'm going
to show you how my solution unfolds
if x and y take on these values then
what i can do is i can put
that x and that y directly into the amgm
inequality
that i proved in part one so here's the
am right can you recognize that
here's the x plus y all over 2
and then here's the square root of x y
that's it and i've just done a straight
substitution
you can see on the right hand side
you've got a whole bunch of cancelling
that happens you've got this cancels
with this
you've got just be careful here the p
plus q cancels with the p
plus q that is in that top numerator
after you've taken out that factor of
two
and the two that's left up here once you
factorize it out that's what's left
underneath the square root here square
root of two
just for convenience because i've got
this fractions on fractions business
over here on the left hand side
i've multiplied both sides of the
inequality by 2 so that's how you get 2
root 2 over here
and then lastly in this first line of
working i've said whoa what's going on
here with these two fractions
my most instinctive thing is to combine
them into one
by getting common denominators now it is
worth noting that i'm not going to leave
them
as a one fraction because if you think
about the result we're trying to prove
or the expression we're trying to
understand it's got two fractions
yeah so i don't want to just keep these
as a single fraction these terms when i
add them up
however i also notice that the
denominators are rather different you've
got a p squared minus q squared here
which i can factorize into p minus q p
plus q
so you're like oh that's going to come
from this common denominator and then
you've got 2p
minus 2q which um it might be helpful if
i wrote this down
these this also you can see comes from
this denominator over here it's just
somehow looking backwards over there so
you can see that
i'm going to eventually separate out
again into two separate fractions
it's just not these fractions that i've
started with here
i definitely don't want a p plus q over
here i'm going to have to do some more
work with that okay so coming back to my
solution here
you can see what i've done is i have got
the common denominator
i've got this mess up the top here but
i've just expanded that's why it looks
so messy
i've got some like terms but i haven't
just
sort of put them together uh what's the
word i'm looking for indiscriminately
right um for example you can see here
what i've got
from this uh not that one there wrong
line and what i've got here
the p squared plus 2pq plus q squared
you might say to me
you know how come you didn't combine the
like terms p
squared q squared with 2p squared 2q
squared a lot of students did that and
said
3p squared plus 3q squared not
not an unusual thing to do but also not
a helpful thing to do because you can't
then factorize that easily
whereas what i've got over here on the
left that's a perfect square
p plus q all squared why would i want p
plus q all squared and the answer is
it's going to cancel with one of the p
plus q's down here
so that's how i knew to do that i left
the t the 2p
squared plus 2q squared over here so you
can see that came from
here and here and then
you can see from there it's relatively
straightforward you get that perfect
square factorized up here on the top
and it's going to it's going to cancel
shortly because you can see
that p plus q and that p plus q they
cancel
and then over here on the right hand
side i want that p
squared plus q squared because if you
have a look back at the result here
look that's what appears right here p
squared plus q squared i want
i want those so that's why i didn't
completely collect those like terms
you can then see in order to go from
this line to the line that i want i had
to divide back through by two so in some
senses i didn't need to multiply through
by two
um to do this simplification but it made
it tons easier for me because then i
didn't
write these two big fractions on another
big fraction
now because this is the expression i was
trying to work with i wanted to find the
minimum value of this
my inequality tells me that this whole
expression here
has to be greater than or equal to root
2.
greater than or equal to root two what
that means is root two is the lowest it
can possibly go
in other words the minimum possible
value
for this big long expression is root two
so
there you go i've now evaluated
successfully
i will show you just very quickly even
though materially it is the same
this is not the only way you can set out
your solution method one what i did was
i started with part one i started with
my amgm inequality
x plus y over two is greater than or
equal to the square root of
x times y that's where i began for
method one but for method two
what i can do is i can start with that
expression they gave us right
here is that expression here and i can
just say what happens when i simplify
this thing does it help me
at all and essentially what i'm going to
do is go through exactly the same
algebraic manipulation and logic that i
did before
but in reverse order because previously
i ended here but now i'm going to start
here
it's not a proof question so that's
totally fine right what i'm going to do
is i start there i combine these
fractions and kind of everything
unfolds but just backwards right i end
up
here and i say to myself hold on a
second this
this expression in here is equal to
a because uh you can see that's what
happens when i um
add x plus y over two in there
and therefore this the smallest that
that can be
is going to be uh b because by part one
a is greater than or equal to b so the
smallest possible value that a can take
on
is b itself and by the way that happens
when your two numbers
are the same when x and y are the same
you get them being equal to each other
so therefore i can just evaluate that
and when you can see
just like i did before that you can
cancel a whole bunch of things there you
just get rid too
um so you're done you have to employ a
bit more
you have to go back on your logic a
little more so this way of working it
out
is longer but in terms of the actual
thinking it is much the same so either
of those would be fine